um I have a very kind of a long one so
Bobby you have to keep up with me okay
paraphrase it because I didn't want to
answer this question in a message and it
was directed directly at me so I figured
I'd kick the can of worms over to you
guys okay so long story short that
usually means the longest story ever my
girlfriend broke up with me five days
ago five days as she broke up with me
she told me she cheated on me a couple
nights ago we lived together and she
paid the last month she offered that I
can stay as long as I want I have
nowhere else to go due to how expensive
rent is in the area only option is to go
back down south to my family it's really
the last thing I want to do since I'm
still staying here although most of my
friends told me to leave and not stay
I've decided to stay anyways and find
closure these past three days it seems
we had a huge spark between us we
planned for a kid in the future and she
promised you'll have a baby in the
future
and that we will get married we had sex
more times in the past few days and we
did all last month the sex and a love is
like how it was two years ago when he's
first started dated we first are dating
passionate and in love again we still
buy anyways here I want to stay here for
the last month and have the time of our
lives together and do a lot of things we
missed out on I haven't told her I've
forgiven her but I'm acting like I did
and she's getting it anyways but here's
the question mm-hmm she's she has been a
hundred percent honest with me when I
asked about the other guy she answered a
lot of my questions about them and a
love of law
I'm extremely conflicted and not sure if
I'm being fair to myself she's still
[ __ ] she's she's [ __ ] other dudes
still and still but telling him about it
I usually stop it I say what I want to
say oh my god whipping-boy
basically that's his dilemma he's like
he wants to this is what you're doing
this is what I would do is you go okay
you wanna break up you cheated on me
fine I'll stay here until I get my um
back on my feet I'll live through the
pain suffer through it right but you
don't [ __ ] her again and you close the
door nur she's done with you you you are
way more okay you mean you got to
respect yourself man
but the [ __ ] are you doing she'd she she
crossed that line and [ __ ] lied to
you that lying in that way cheating
right is the biggest sabotage okay like
if you cheated on me yeah I'm just a
little right right herb right yeah yeah
good job
no you big you [ __ ] right Brendan yeah
what I'm saying I love Brendan okay but
my point is is this okay is if you did
you would see a side of me you've never
seen before I want to get violent but I
would get even okay he doesn't believe
in yourself man leave her uh yeah she
doesn't respect you back yeah but also
you I understand what he's doing he's
just so desperate to have a little bit
left of her or with her so he thinks
that she's not changing your mind she's
still [ __ ] other dudes coming home
and [ __ ] you she's basically leading
her having her cake and eating it too
and I'm not gonna lie I think that I
have been that girl before and I'm gonna
tell you right now that I didn't have I
there was I didn't have respect for guys
like you I've done a lot of bad [ __ ] in
my past and I've I've come home to a
person and told him yeah I've slept with
other people and he still wanted to have
me in his life cuz I don't know and I I
didn't have respect for him really mmm
that's the perfect answer he was like a
doormat you know and I just kept him for
like convenience or like just and I feel
really [ __ ] up even talking about it
it's not a good but thank God that
person was Kobe Bryant the person is
still and yeah that person is still one
of my best friends now but he'll be the
first to tell you like get the [ __ ] out
yeah you know we should have him on the
show but yeah like he he was you and he
hated me ended up hating me for a long
time before we patched things up and
became good friends
[Music]